healthcare sector
amazing and nicole so my name is nicole
princeton
i'm one of the co-founders at this is
prime we are a specialist at graduate
recruitment agency and focus on sales
and recruitment sectors
um been established since well about
seven years now
started in manchester uh then launched
london three years ago and we are now uk
and us
wide team down london's quite small
team manchester's bigger um but the
market is booming right now so we're all
very happy people at prime
level and then last but not least tom hi
i'm tom morris
uh managing director and founder of tdm
recruitment we operate
in the residential property and property
sector across the uk
um there is 13 head count within the
business
and we are one of the work from anywhere
flexi working so we don't necessarily
have an office uh per se so
our team is across the southeast um so
we're one of the new breeds but
um yeah life is good and uh market is
buoyant so
um yeah that's me and us love to hear it
awesome
so just to i guess set the scene for
this session and what we're going to be
doing so first 20 30 minutes of this
we're there's a couple of questions that
we put together that we're going to be
asking the panelists and then after the
sort of uh those 20 30 minutes we're
then gonna be answering all of your
questions
um a number of you submitted questions
before
this event and also uh if any of you do
have questions at any point use the chat
box as i've mentioned
and we'll get those answered so just i
guess to
set the the scene here i think it goes
hopefully goes about saying that
for any of the panelists here if they do
share anything that
um is personal to them that sort of
respect that and make sure that we all
feel this is a safe place and
comfortable place to share things
but i just wanted to sort of share i
guess
how people define resilience um online
um i found the definition that i've sort
of really resonated with but
most of the places uh had a similar
definition and the definition is
resilience is the ability to withstand
adversity and bounce back from
difficult life events but being
resilient does not mean that people
don't experience stress emotional
upheaval and suffering
and some people equate resilience with
mental toughness but demonstrating
resilience includes working through
emotional pain and suffering and i just
thought that was a really
a well put together definition and
the final thing that i also found that i
think what thought was really
interesting to tee up this conversation
today was
um a really famous pediatrician who
uh supports children and adolescents
build resilience came up this
with this really famous model called the
seven seas um
which were learning competence
confidence connection
character contribution coping and
control
is how this doctor feels that you can
build inner strength that you can do
regardless of your age and i thought
that was um
really interesting so i guess to kick
this off
um ron i'm gonna come back to you first
if that's okay
let's let's start with like how what
does resilience mean
to you firstly how would you define it
and why do you believe it's important in
recruitment
so it's a funny one i've been i've said
to you before since we just asked me to
come and do this i've been asking myself
that question
every day and what does it mean to me
i've been through some traumatic things
so resilience to me
means different thing to a lot of
different people and everyone has a
different i like to say plate
size of what they can deal with so in
recruitment i'd suggest
it's obviously dealing with the stress
of a client or a candidate
getting business on and then downs and
lows and highs but
i look at resilience as in going through
some really traumatic stuff as a person
and then be able to bounce back and
recover from it and then also support
other people that's my
view on resilience but everyone's
different everyone's gone through
different types of things in life so
it's each to their own what someone else
would call resilience i
i would and this is one of the questions
a bit further down
and was about um i can't what it was
about um
dealing with um seeing finding empathy
on other people's resilience as well
which i struggle with sometimes because
i've been through
something quite tough and then i see
other people not dealing with things
and i'm like where's your resilience but
i don't say that but i think it
yeah yeah interesting nicole same
question to you then like one what does
resilience mean to you how would you
define it and
why why do you think it's important in
recruitment um
some some things i think are aligned
with ryan on there but for me i think
resilience is obviously all about
developing that ability to
sort of quickly and consistently just
bounce back and grow from each challenge
that you face and i guess it's that
ability to always just pick yourself
back
up when you get knocked down especially
in recruitment and i think
you have to recognize and accept that
the struggles are real in recruitment
and getting knocked down is inevitable
but
you've got to just keep learning from
those challenges and resilience will
develop
and ensure that you just continue to
grow and succeed in your career but
i think in recruitment is important to
identify that
resilience isn't just about gritting
your teeth and getting on with it and
just getting through it there has to be
an intelligent approach to what you're
doing as well
so i think someone put it on one of my
posts today about doing the same thing
over and over and getting the same
result isn't resilience if it's not
there has to be a level of strategy
that helps you progress and resilience
is great but it's got to be channeled in
the right way so
i guess it's about knowing how to
control our emotions and
in those difficult and challenging
situations
and when we're under pressure we do
often react emotionally and then logic
goes out the window and i'm i'm guilty
of that myself many a time in
recruitment but
we just need to be able to recognize
what we can and we can't control and i
think that's where resilience becomes
really key
you recognize the controllables and you
learn to sometimes
just accept the uncontrollables because
you've been through experiences where
you've had to develop that resilience
and learn
that you can't control everything but
you find the things that are within your
control and you focus on those and
that's what keeps you moving forward so
for me
i'd say that's why it's so important
particularly in recruitment
to be resilient by nature love that
tom last but not least what what does
resilience mean to you
like that important recruitment is
critical quite frankly
um and similarly to what i said before
um i think resilience is ultimately the
ability to manage failure
i think in life in general um
particularly nowadays people don't
really like to talk about failure
but i think if you are accepting of
failure and
you know every single day and every week
you know
three of us four of us except that um
failure isn't just part of life that's
part of recruitment unfortunately
um it's the only job in the world where
your product ultimately can turn around
and say no i'm not being sold today
um and you learn that very very quickly
you have people who sell houses people
sell cars or
sell whatever um their product does not
say no
um and you can say no at any point and
it can even say no on the day that it
starts
um as well so um the ability to manage
that
um and me and my team actually had a
similar conversation about candidate
generation on monday
because every man this dog uh is
struggling for candidate generation
um at the moment but it's it's managing
that
um understanding that candidates you
know
necessarily aren't on the tree that you
can go and pick
um and i think that's really resilience
it's not necessarily just the ability to
keep going because
that definition of madness as as they
said is
doing the same thing expecting different
results but um yeah
i think it's incredibly important it's
everything that happens in recruitment
except quite frankly something happens
in life
um the ability to to manage the ups and
downs
um life is not easy yeah thank you so
nicole i'm gonna come back to you
i'm gonna ask you the sort of next
question and with everyone that's with
us now i've found something that you may
be thinking okay well
i would say i'm quite resilient and
there's been quite a few studies on this
where
sometimes people actually over um
think that well they think that they're
more resilient than they actually are
so what i'm going to share with you all
really quickly is
something where you can actually take a
resilience assessment and actually work
out how resilient you are
so that's something that maybe you could
do in your own time later that i think
all of you could potentially find really
useful to actually have a bit of an idea
of like how resilient actually are you
um and where do you score on that and it
may sort of produce some gaps or
areas that you could um look at to
improve
but nicole want to come to you basically
so i guess
so we've spoken a bit about that so how
do you believe yourself then personally
have you how have you cultivated more
resilience do you think like how have
you gone about that
um and then two is it actually something
that maybe you
feel like you've actually always had
that you've tapped into
um i personally then obviously want
everyone's got different opinions i
personally think resilience comes from
the mind and it is inherent in everybody
but whether people then choose to use or
develop it really just comes down to
that individual so i don't think it's a
you have it or you don't have it right i
just think it's a skill you develop
through the experiences that you have
like ryan touched me earlier about
trauma in your life and things like that
and i do think the challenges you face
throughout your life will develop that
resilience and it is both a mental and
physical strength with resilience so
i think my personal resilience has
definitely been developed through both
my personal life experiences as well as
my professional experiences
and i think it's become a lot more
evidence in my performance
my actions my achievements as my careers
actually continue to progress
later on in life than maybe earlier on
where maybe didn't take it as seriously
um but a lot a lot he said about having
a why it's such a big topic isn't it and
i do believe that
that is massively linked to resilience
like your reasons to continue
with something must always be bigger
than your reasons to stop
doing something and if you live by that
you can achieve pretty much anything i
didn't come up with that by the way i
got that from um
bosses with his amazing swim around the
gp like kind of well yeah yeah but like
but
you really cultivated that you've really
made sure that you you've got that
anchor point of like why am i doing this
absolutely and these things yeah that's
interesting it's so important because
you're going to get knocked down a lot
and you'll be
you've got to know why you've got to
keep going so i think that that was one
of my biggest lessons i think more so in
the last
five to 10 years when my wife's become
much more relevant more important
and therefore if i want to continue
doing something
that's more important to me than if i
stop doing what i'm doing so for me
i think cultivating it and did i already
have it
yes i think everyone's got it somewhere
but have i developed it yes 100
and i think that's down to identifying
what's more important and having that
why and
definitely agree with ryan the more
things you suffer in life and the more
things you go through
the more your resilience will naturally
develop to as a result
so just quickly on that nicole before i
asked the other chats like
uh because i think sometimes people can
i can get really hung up on like
one like really finding it hard to find
like this concrete wine and like once
you've got it you've got it sort of
thing but has it has it changed for you
has it evolved has that been yeah i
think that's just an important thing for
you to share yeah
because it's never like because it's
always like oh i don't know what to do
with my life and like everyone's just
waiting for this like
perfect moment where everything's
perfect but i think that why it can
can change and can evolve but it's just
important you understand like you said
you know why you're doing it and it's
bigger than your reason for stopping
so totally in the graduate market as
well like we speak to graduates every
day and you said you might want your
goals for yourself and they don't have
like like you're almost thinking right
you want to buy a house in three years
don't you like
they don't know and i look back when i
was that age and going god i just wanted
to have a good time in recruitment i
wanted to work hard make money enjoy
life
whereas now my why's are so so different
um
because you experience different things
as you grow older and different things
happen in your life
your why's become so so different but
they become more important as well as a
result so for me that that's quite a key
thing to
to really drive your resilience forward
love that ryan let me come to you then
how
how do you cultivate residents you think
personally and
and or do you think it's something that
you maybe have always had from
growing up i started with nicole is i
think
everyone has some sort of resilience it
just depends what you get tested on i
think
more all for your career and both with
personal life it's
depending on your job i think as well
and that running a business
that's obviously going to test you in so
many different dynamics not just doing
recruitment as a sole role and then if
you become good at recruitment and
become a team leader then you'll have
more resilience about looking after them
team members
i think you get different growths and
resilience as you grow as a person as
your career
does um but yeah do i think
yeah um that's a funny one
for me personally i i definitely grew up
resilience as
having a business getting into
recruitment and being in sales my whole
life
and having to grip my teeth and get on
with the job so to speak
and and that's how i've learned
resilience but then in personal life
i've got some massive dramas happened to
me which means i've just got
picked myself back up the floor looked
after mental health
found ways of getting back into get on
track and getting back into work and
making the business work so
i thought that's how i see my resilience
and how it's kind of red yeah
that's how i see mine when i talk to
team resident members about their
resilience
i think it's just that culture of like
this is how you deal with it and
again the definitions of not doing
something the same again
is yeah if they're going for a difficult
time with a particular client or
something like that
let's try a different time this way and
remember we don't do it that way this
time
you'll learn every time i think that
probably is learning resilience
i don't know if i can teach it i don't
know if i is teaching someone actually
but
it's definitely every time something
goes wrong let's try and fix it and make
it better
and i think that probably is my
definition of building resilience
tom what about you what what comes up to
you um how have you cultivated is it
again being sort of professional and
personal
circumstances you found yourselves in or
yeah yeah
a bit of both really i i mean um
i suppose it ultimately comes down to
what what you want in life is my opinion
um and for me you know
i i moved into well i fell into
recruitment
um but i you know i was a very shy i'm
not shy but i i wasn't a natural phone
person or sales person
and i wanted to have a life that um
that others didn't and uh to do that i
had to put myself in a situation so i
went and sold
um uh advertising space in the back of
an nhs trade magazine for six months
uh sat on the phone drove two hours
there two hours back um
worked for the guy that sat on a a
raised platform smoking his cigar
uh and they are left i left because he
chucked his shoe at the girl next to me
so
and he was like 20 meters away so
know resilience uh i think you
everyone has it as people said
intrinsically within them but it's um
how you develop it and you look for
evidence within your life
um and ultimately to have um to be
successful and that's not necessarily
just in recruitment or
money or whatever um my wife you know
she's had
four children she's extremely resilient
um but she doesn't
value you know the money side of things
or or wants to be in business and things
like that
so i suppose you have to be very careful
in terms of
equating resilience to material things
or monetary things
um and how far and how uh how
how far you get in life and business but
um yeah it can be cultivated but
it's within everyone it's just whether
they decide to um
to look for it and develop it and put
themselves in comfortable situations but
also knowing that if it is too
uncomfortable to step back
um and the dangers that that can cause
yeah
so we've had a few comments here and
we're going to start now
sort of taking this conversation and all
you free of business owners you lead
teams and
i think people really interested in like
okay well you're spoking about
yourselves and what you think has
contributed to your own resilience but
how can we then
yeah start trying to encourage our
employees colleagues
um on this journey as well because it's
obviously so important
but i think this is a really interesting
point that nigel has put here where he
said basically
and i think this is really interesting
where it's like for me it's about
framing what actually is an
up and what is a down in recruitment we
can we're guilty of only celebrating the
placements as arts
but so many other points should be
celebrated and
the downs he is is a candidate dropping
out
really a down is that something that we
should be perceiving as a down so
we should be learning from each
experience but should it should it
should be seen as inevitable it's about
setting expectations i think that's a
really interesting point isn't it
on like firstly let's like understand
okay what are the
highs in recruitment what are the lows
and and our even our perception of that
can impact
i guess our resilience and how we bounce
back on things
yeah i think we set our own highs and
lows unfortunately i mean you hear the
[ __ ]
the frey champagne and razor blades um
and you know i'm old school
um you know i'm of the background we're
50 60 phone calls
a day six o'clock in the morning until
seven o'clock at night um
those that well doesn't exist anymore
thank god but um yeah i think
it's not necessarily all about the deal
um
some businesses are like that but let's
be honest they're very much boiler room
um activity um recruitment is a much
more mature market and
there's another question on with from
neil about how do we manage um or how do
we look at uh resilience and
yeah some of the candidates i've
particularly seen come into the market
over the last two or three years
are looking at it from a different
recruitment is now seen as an
aspirational career
um and that the tactics and training
methods have evolved
are long gone but yeah it's candidates
dropping out yes it's bad but it isn't
the worst thing that could happen you
can learn from it
yeah for sure so as we go into this and
nikon will come to you
i'm going to share a poll with you all
and it'd be great to hear your thoughts
on this let's just
i guess just ask this question um on
look do you believe that resilience um
can be learned and taught right so i
guess
nicole for you then in building your own
recruitment business
like how how do you feel like what sort
of helped you
encourage your colleagues team
to be more resilient do you think what
things have worked how have you
maybe taken them on a journey of
learning to be more resilient like what
comes up for you there what things have
worked do you think it's the interesting
one is nick so i ran that poll on
on linkedin about can resilience be
trained
and tall and like over nearly 300 people
have voted and it's
67 percent of people say yes and the
rest they know and it's quite
interesting because it's quite a torn
thought process for me i think
i said earlier it's inherent everyone we
all have it i think resilience can be
learned not taught so when you're trying
to
cultivate it into your team you have to
be really aware of that like
you can teach anyone anything but
ultimately it comes down to whether they
want to learn it or not so
that's down to them not not necessarily
down to you so
we can teach and train what resilience
is but you can't then help make it
happen they've got to want to make it
themselves that's where the why i guess
comes in but
in terms of cultivating resilience
within your teams i think you've got to
have a culture where
it's okay to make mistakes um i came
from a culture
that it was it was almost embraced like
you've got to make mistakes to learn and
develop and if you're not making
mistakes you're not testing
yourself you're not pushing yourself out
of your comfort zone you're not trying
like something new
so don't be afraid to make mistakes
because that's where your confidence
comes from your resilience comes from
helping people get comfortable with
being uncomfortable
i think is important as well take
yourself out of that comfort zone
it's good for you to get out of your
comfort zone because it will help build
your resilience so
creating an environment in which people
can get comfortable in doing that
is going to be key to developing and
cultivating that resilience within your
team
so i think in recruitment i think that
point is valid like we've got this
belief that if it's a dropout it's such
a bad thing and if
it goes in it's a great thing and we've
created that ourselves but
ultimately we are results driven by
nature in recruitment so that's what
we're aiming
for but it's the case of like if it
didn't go your way that's all right
as long as we know why and we learn from
that and we're comfortable with being
pushed and challenged throughout and
that's i think where our resilience will
be
developed through our culture when we're
building our teams which are
predominantly graduates coming through
into the team
interesting ryan what what about you
then obviously you have a
number of people that obviously the way
that your business works you have
franchisees and stuff like this and i'm
sure you're you'll be communicating to
them
really early on how important it is that
they're able to bounce back
learn from things so yeah how have you
gone about cultivating it
yeah it's like nobody rises to low
expectations is it
setting them expectations of what they
what they call let's call financial
success because there's lots of
different successes in life but
a financial success and then if that's
their goal
which it generally is if you're going to
set up a business or be in recruitment
how are you going to get there and
that's only going to happen exactly from
that
is making mistakes and things going
[ __ ] wrong
because when things go tips up is when
you're learning it and that's anything
right we're going to do that again this
time
i'm going to change it this time i want
to make sure i'll do that about the next
time and then guess what next time it
goes a bit more right and
things don't go wrong and you're
covering your bases i think
maybe that is the teaching in it that is
the teaching of resilience there is
learning from your mistakes every time
and then building on it from there
so i guess with franchisees we've never
done recruitment before
it's teaching them look it's gonna be
it's gonna be tough this isn't gonna be
easy
about and being calm with them and
talking through it to the next stage
but that didn't go that way because of
this so next time we'll do this phone
call the next meeting we go to
we're going to change it for this and i
guess that's the way we teach resilience
or
yeah he's doing the job isn't it
understanding there's ups and downs it's
like a roller coaster
get used to it buckle in that's what you
signed up for
and so i want to bring this over to you
but i want to add something to it
because i think this is my other
question where i feel like the way that
we're talking about is very
much linked to what you hear a lot in
recruitment which is having a growth
mindset and not a fixed mindset and
that's very much linked to what we're
talking about right and
being able to yeah take a step back and
go right okay so that didn't work i'm
gonna try this next time
and these types of things rather than um
yeah deciding the like i've failed so
i'm not good at it and i can't do it
sort of thing
so i guess how like are you like do you
share
ryan and nicole's thoughts on like have
you made in in your business
you made it aware that you can fail we
want you to fail or
it's we want to create a safe place for
people to get out their comfort zone
like what comes up for you on call of
duty
100 i mean there's a book called black
box thinking i don't know if anyone else
no
matter outside yeah it's a great um it's
great but and um
bizarrely i mean i'm me and my family
are
our direct um exp well we're
experiencing the
the failures of the nhs at the moment
through a variety of things and
the way that they have dealt with
failure which is catastrophic failure
um is is quite um
quite disturbing uh they close ranks
they don't accept anything they blame
everyone else but themselves
um and ultimately they have got to a
point whereby
the only situation is that they can just
sit themselves in the corner and
and sort of bat away every problem but
yeah if you accept that there is
problems and except there are failures
um and and pick over them uh and
accept that that's the way it is
you will grow as a person you'll grow as
a professional
um the phrase i always use is they see
the other
side of the coin or i see put yourself
in someone else's shoes
um and ultimately you know when can they
just use that example candidates reject
offers or clients decide to
retain someone else or decide to use
another recruiter exclusively
i always encourage the teams to actually
ask the question if you're in their
situation why would they choose to do
that and as soon as you look at it from
their perspective
you actually realize why your actions
were not right or how what you could
have done better
um so you know there are times where
people do need to shake and say look
this is you absolutely screwed up here
um
what have you done this um but if it's a
genuine mistake or there's nothing they
can do
then then so be it it is what it is uh
no one's died
everyone's okay um let's learn and move
on and i think
you get less resilient people in a very
blameless culture um we've got a number
of competitors that are like that and
i've interviewed candidates from those
businesses and they're good recruiters
but i wouldn't take them into my
business because
they would just literally cause havoc um
and
they're hiding stuff so um i would have
rather
have someone who's quite open and say
that i've really messed up here um
there's someone that pretending that
everything's okay and then unfortunately
fine there's a
hand grenade in the back pocket so yeah
so i wanted so i'm gonna i want to jump
into
audience questions here and i think
tony's made
it's not quite a question but i'm gonna
i want to take a question from it so i
can
bring it up on the screen so you can all
see it so tony said i believe the
resiliences of quality which are
developed over time people learn from
people and the emotive ways that others
react to bad news is often picked up and
replicated as being the way
we should react i knew a recruiter
always used to throw his paperwork phone
and everything else across the office
when he got bad news guess what
that display of angle is quickly
replicated by the newer team members
so the question i have for you because
i'm sure you've all seen this firsthand
i definitely experienced it in an office
of like a
which then became like 12 people
recruitment business where you know when
someone's
had [ __ ] news and then they let it ruin
the rest of their day
right you just know it you can feel it
it's a bit awkward
like you're like oh should i stay away
from them so i guess the question is
nikon's going to come to you
for people that you sense are maybe
having a hard time
doing the things that we're talking
about and maybe react in a way
that isn't one um helping themselves but
isn't helping the team
how do we deal with that how have you
dealt with that in the past out of
interest
it's a tough one isn't it because then
emotion is quite high
i think um tom touched earlier on
products people at the end of the day so
it is quite an emotive industry that
we're in um
i think it's about educating people and
taking control over what they can
and what what and leaving what they
can't and what they can control of their
actions and their attitude
um and you need to try and drive quite a
solution-focused mindset because
dealing with it that way isn't resolving
the situation the situation is still
what it is
that that is that has happened but
dealing in that way isn't going to
resolve it i remember
years ago i was in a recruitment team
where that exactly situation
thousands in commission for them so i
could understand the reaction they're
pretty much smashing their computer up
at the time
but it didn't resolve the situation and
what i was trying to say to them was
like
i totally get why you're reacting that
way i'd be livid myself like that's a
lot of money
but you have to try and now fix it like
spend the rest of the day
like this isn't resolving anything
ultimately there must have been other
candidates in the pipeline that were
close or were really good or there were
people that come through on your ad that
you haven't spoken to yet because you
thought you feeled it
you got to find a solution you need to
get back onto that client you need to
get that retained and get that field and
get your money back
and when you start to find a solution
and start to re-channel that focus and
remove the emotion and start
driving the logic then you can start to
channel the the motivations back in the
right way but
everyone's entitled to have a little bit
of a moment yeah yeah like that's what
you
accept it i'm with you understand but
then it's like right next channel
instead of letting this ruin the rest of
our day yeah so just to evolve this a
bit tom i'm going to come to you
just to evolve this a bit because of
what you said around the way that you're
thinking about your business moving
forward
i'm just curious what does that look
like in a remote hybrid world
where do you know what i mean i think
that's interesting like how do you spot
that
how do you see that and then potentially
help them channel that energy that
nicole just mentioned out of interest
yeah
i mean it is a difficult thing to manage
remotely i certainly learned a new set
of skills over the last 18 months
um i think for me
you know as a business we have two uh
zoo meetings
uh a town hall catch up a week and
it's how people present themselves in
those meetings um
and you know people have bad weeks but
also the other thing
is honesty you know we go back to that
um yeah i think a lot of anger and
and frustration comes when people aren't
honest with themselves um i mean i have
no problem
actually with someone doing that but
um as long as it wasn't all day every
day um i think um
if someone that i've had people before
who have done similar things that you
know
i'm sure i've been the thing is now
they're just going to be disrupting
their whole family
as like yeah that's not the office
i think it's you can see the way people
are
you know i've learned how to read teams
messages you've learned how to you know
i suppose it's more important about
checking in with people and yeah yeah
the mental health side of things and um
almost normalizing
failure um remotely um and
the thing that we looked at we're
starting to look at is actually
do league tables actually perform any is
there any real
positive intention behind league tables
do you need them um what's the intention
for someone
smashing it so you know someone's not
doing great do they really need to be
told every week they're not doing great
on a league table i think they
understand what their billings are if
they don't then they're probably
in the wrong job so um it's a difficult
one it is a difficult one there's no
right answer but
um i think as long as when people are
talking to their colleagues or when
they're in group chats they're
respectful
um they're you know friendly um
and honest with themselves um
it isn't for everyone the the the way
we're structured but it yeah ultimately
if people
have the offices and and peacock up and
down um
and then it's going to work for other
businesses quite frankly yeah okay
yeah i guess i guess the point there is
you're gonna you just have to be way
more intentional
conscious of like when you need to check
in find out but as you said
your culture and the business you're
building is look we all need to be
honest with each other and that's why
we're doing that which is obviously an
important fact
to that but i was i was curious um so
yeah so ryan i'm gonna i'm gonna get
your thoughts on this so
um apparel has um added this i'm just
going to add a bit more context to this
because i think this is a bit more of a
coping mechanism that might be useful
for people which i'm going to
just show on the screen which is
basically to descent
decentralized to yourself can't get my
words out to like the highs and lows and
i think that is a good coping mechanism
i think is like
when the highs are really high like i
think some people and you definitely
learn this early on in recruitment like
not to be like oh my god right i'm going
to buy all this stuff this month for
like
just get really swept away with the
highs and when the lows are lows
um maybe not to let that affect you as
much so i guess ryan the point here is
what do you think of that it's
expectations again that one extreme
expectation expect things are going to
go wrong
expect that things are going to go
really well and don't
be walking around opening bottles of
champagne dancing
when you get a good deal in but then
afternoon yeah
yeah but then don't jump out the window
when things go wrong
yeah yeah so i think peru what you said
there is a really good point it is like
yeah
yeah i think that's a good coping
mechanism of like okay i am going to
enjoy this
but let's not get carried away here and
let yeah
so i think that's an interesting one
isn't it i think that's a bit of a
maturity as well though as you've been
doing for a while and you've
learned wait a minute if i go around
walking around like king dick at the
minute i know next week when things go
wrong they want to be something that's
fine
they're the yo-yo builders aren't they
really the ones who feel bigger
yeah yeah so um i want to come to our
next point there's a few other questions
that the audience have submitted that i
wanted to get through but i want to make
sure we answer
neil's question here so nikon will come
to you again so i could come to you
first to these questions but
you you're perfectly placed for this but
and i'm keen to hear ron and tom's
thoughts on this because
one of the questions i have for both of
you guys
is i guess just what you're seeing in
the quote unquote younger generation
like do you feel they are more resilient
do they think they do have as much
resilience as maybe you feel like you
had when you were growing up
not sure but like how how can we start
obviously a lot of recruitment
businesses are hiring they want to build
their own talent and this is neil's
question so how
can you test or see if candidates for
your own business
have resilience if they don't have maybe
prior life experiences they had to go
for it like what
what what's your thoughts on that nicole
how can we identify resilience in people
for our teams and
for for our businesses um i think it's
an interesting one because you said
yourself like is
is the younger generation like uh
entering the recruitment
industry like less resilient and i don't
think it's that they're less resilient i
think that potentially they're less
patient
um they've grown up in a society where
instant gratification is just the norm
for them so they don't have to wait
for long to get much these days so
you've got google alexa siri
amazon next to library uber everything
it's quite quick everything's very quick
and that's become part of their life and
then you go into recruitment it's so
different where it's such
a deferred gratification status like
you've got to wait and patience is
really key
and that's where you you need to dig
deep for that resilience to keep going
um in terms of the younger generation
being resilient
i think again it comes down to the
individual people
people who faced sort of challenges
earlier in their life
have obviously learned and developed
their resilience at a younger age than
those
that have not maybe faced so many tough
challenges going through life so
i think the challenge of then goes those
that haven't experienced those same
challenges do you find it harder to
showcase their resilience it doesn't
mean they don't have it or can't develop
it it's
just that they don't have the ability to
convince others they've got it yet
because they may not have been tested in
the same way as others so they haven't
had that
i mean a lot of my tests in resilience
have come later on in my life rather
than early on in my life so if someone
asked me that question
how would i prove it or i played played
hockey or i did football refereeing it's
not a huge test of resilience is it
but you don't really get massive some
people have those tests and then they're
able to showcase it a lot younger
so testing it in an interview process is
quite tough i think you obviously have
to
ask for examples of where they've
demonstrated resilience or they've faced
failure or they've come
up against challenges and it's less
about what those things are and more
about their process of how they dealt
with
them how they got through them how they
overcame them what they learnt from them
more importantly
but you can't always test it in an
interview
you've just got to really identify
where they come from what's their
journey and what do they really want
like do they know what they want where
they want to go and then we can only
really test the competencies but i think
it is hard to test in the younger
generation but you can ask the right
questions but you're only going to get a
certain level which is why i think a lot
of the questions set when we're
interviewing graduates as much more
about their past
and where they've come from what their
journey has been like to really
understand
where they where their challenges have
been um and how they've dealt with those
moving forwards but
it is a tough one for graduates coming
because not everyone has experienced
challenges at that age and
and how do they then showcase their
resilient it doesn't mean they're not
they just haven't had the time i think i
think the point i made from that is i
guess
and tom i'm going to ask you like how
you i guess trying to look for this in
people you hired for your business but i
think the point i took from that really
quickly is
yeah i guess it's back to what all of
you said of around like getting really
good at understanding
what worked why didn't work taking that
on board moving that forward and if
you're
speaking to younger people coming to the
recruitment industry and they're going i
didn't achieve this because of that or
this didn't happen because that happened
to me and it's a bit more of a point in
the finger and
not taking responsibility and saying
this is what would have done differently
then that's maybe something that
yeah would go i'm not sure if they is
that something that they do have
resilience some from what you said but
tom what what comes up for you how do
you try and identify resilience
i think that's a great point hashem
about really about um
the the when you i've interviewed so
many people
over the years but you know even at
graduate or trainee level
um i think that there is a lot of um
people who are quite happy to sit and
blame other things for why they stopped
doing stuff
i think that would always be well it
would always be a red flag for me
um yeah i mean people don't necessarily
it's not like an x factor final where
someone's had a sob story um you know
you don't expect that every person you
interview or every person you offer a
job for but
for me it's doing things outside of
education you know
graduates um and trainees now so well
prep for interview they know exactly
what to say
when to say it how to say it they know
it's our mirror
interview um and um yeah we never saw
people like nicole
yeah no no but it's fair play to them
but you just try and get them onto a
normal level
yeah talk to them about stuff outside of
their education you know i would look
for someone who's
um you know tried uh to become you know
nicole said about football coaching or
football refereeing uh
that for me would be a great thing if
someone's willing to do something
outside of
their in their free time to a a decent
level
they have to put some time and effort
into it um that would show resilience if
they're not being financially rewarded
for it or it's not going to get them
along they're doing it for a passion
then i would personally be very
interested in that type of person so
that's what i would look for not
necessarily someone who's
sold the middle east peace process or
has got a cure for
um hunger um you know it's it's
very easy to be dismissive of
mundane things but for me i'd be very
interested in someone who
was a grade 8 on the piano or something
like that
nothing to do with recruitment but it
shows a commitment and a level of
mental toughness to continue doing
something for a passion
rather than any monetary gains so yeah
it's um
but i wouldn't say that the younger
generation are
in any way shape less resilient i think
that
in many ways life now is much more
complicated than um
when i was uh entering the world of work
um you know social media is a
um yeah christ um i would yeah i
wouldn't
deny that no no way to start with that
but yeah it's
uh given the bad press ryan what what
kind of
there's there's um i'm really interested
to sort of
segue into when we think maybe yeah i'm
going to ask some questions around maybe
when resilience might be a bad thing or
knowing the difference between sticking
it out or
having resilience but ryan what
obviously you're you're speaking to
people that
trying to be part of your business um
growing the tesla on franchise so like
how do you try and identify resilience
is it some of the similar things that
nicole and
someone said i i wrote down self-care
um because i look for an emotional
intelligence as well
that's just me and my culture the way i
run my business
i like to people to get on my page i'm
quite emotionally intelligent that way
so when i'm talking to someone i'll ask
questions about what they're doing
in the personal time is there any i'll
try and dig deep into that sort of
that's just my
me and how i look at it i completely
grew both they call and talk about how
they're doing you know what they're
looking for as well at the same time but
i think when someone has that self-care
or they talk about emotionally about
themselves sometimes they've definitely
been through some sort of resilient
had some resilience tested there i think
so that's what i look for
so the question on ask now actually came
from um
para as well i've just put it in the
chat but basically
so this is i guess maybe just some
advice for for people that listen
to this back or with us now where it's
like the scenario that apparel gave is
like basically if you find yourself in a
tough role
um maybe in a not so good company how do
you know the difference between like
deciding to stick it out
and build resilience versus maybe
potentially damaging your mental health
or like stepping away
so tom i'm gonna ask you that like what
comes up for you on that like when
i don't know anything any points or
maybe advice or things to think about
when
you might be thinking right am i just
being maybe a bit stubborn here and this
isn't actually serving me and it's
actually being damaging or
should i actually continue to stick it
out and be resilient
it's a great question yes it's a great
question and you know i can relate it to
myself actually i mean i've had mental
health problems um
i i remember standing in the field at
six o'clock in the morning my three
daughters looking at me
crying my eyes out because i've built
business that i hated uh quite frankly
um i had everything but nothing and um i
was the definition of that i just
continued and continued and doing it you
know the big ass fast cars and all the
rest of it and
holidays everyone thought i had
everything but um
it was because i was too resilient
because i just kept going and going and
going
this life that i thought everyone would
want
but when you get there you think you've
reached nirvana but you've reached hell
so um you know yeah resilience is um
it's a great thing to have but you can
go too far
and my advice to anyone you know never
do anything that
makes you desperately unhappy if if it
makes you that unhappy
in recruitment then recruitment's not
for you to be blunt
um and recruitment is really tough um
the nutrition rate is
is will never come down no matter what
happens but
it's not for everyone but it's a fine
line everyone has i think um i can't
remember
earlier on but everyone has different
levels of resilience and i think that's
the critical thing that i've learned
particularly during the pandemic
um within our team you know there are
certain individuals that i've just said
look guys
you need to have some time go away um
you know just
turn your phone off turn the computer
off and just be with your family because
there's there's no good that can happen
by them sitting on on the phone or doing
any more
work um and that is a
very difficult thing but if they're not
at the point where they can understand
it themselves then they've gone too far
um it's yeah it's it's a tough one but
if you
two resilience is is just as as as bad
as there's not enough
yeah so just on this tomorrow because
you thank you for sharing that with us
so i guess
the question i want to ask you i guess
i'm just trying to unearth maybe
what could i guess help people prevent
themselves finding themselves in that
maybe really painful spot so i guess if
you
if you were to think about it in
hindsight what do you think you would
maybe do differently
or maybe say to yourself that you think
could have had an impact on preventing
you get into that
place of like on the field with your
dogs like what like oh my god i like
what have i
got here sort of thing like is there
anything maybe you would have done
differently do you think that could have
prevented you from getting to that
position
um yeah i think
um living a life or developing a life
that um
wasn't what was true to me uh was what
conception of what a recruitment
business owner should be
um rather than actually what i should
what i really wanted
um and when you aren't your
true self i suppose or if you're not
honest with your um
with your purpose and what others have
said and your values
um then you become a a very unhappy
person because you're living
a false life and i think there is a
unfortunate recruitment there's a lot of
if you spoke to most business owners i
reckon you'd probably find a very very
unhappy bunch
um who were living lives that um they
are supposedly
wanting to or what they think they
should be doing wearing those rolexes
driving those fast cars and
you know everything's on uh than never
never um
yeah it's just a load of [ __ ] so
basically yeah
so what you're saying there is actually
it's a bit of self-awareness so hang on
a minute who am i doing this for am i
doing this because
trying to impress other people these
types of things yeah
yeah and it's really interesting listen
to a podcast today and
um they were talking about this sort of
stuff and there was this
famous blog that got published by a lady
who basically
has interviewed like thousands of people
in her deathbed and she asked him like
one of the questions which is what
what one thing do you regret in life and
the the most common answer was
not living to a life that's true to
yourself
so like that's yeah so thank you for
sharing that and i think
um by more people talking about that it
hopefully give them space to ask those
questions like why am i doing this who
is this for
um so nicole where i want to take this
i want to get your thoughts on and
likewise ryan the other question to this
um a chap called lawrence shared this
with us and i think this
could be really apparent for people
right now so the other part i guess on
the resilience piece is does being
resilient blind you from understanding
whether something is worth carrying on
or not
and the context i want to get your
thoughts on is i guess maybe right now
i continue to hear recruiters so they've
got loads of jobs they've got loads on
and it can be really easy to find
yourself just absolutely
just work until eight and nine pm
because you know there's just so much
opportunity there to do deal with
placements etc
so what comes up for you there may be
where we could be a bit blinded by
this is what we do i've got to do it to
then having a good understanding of
maybe when to stop or refocus or i don't
know what comes up for you on that
um that's a good question i think i i
read this somewhere once that they said
there's nothing resilient about
suffering without a strategy and
you should really if you're gonna go for
any sort of pain
you need to have some sort of strategic
management around that pain
i think a lot of us experienced that
last year
through covid it was a painful process
in recruitment for the majority i think
and you
you've got a way up is the pain worth it
have you got a good enough strategy
around why you're doing it and what you
want from it so i think for me
it comes down to that that you've gotten
you've got to have a clear strategy and
if the pain is too much then
it's it's not it's not the right thing
for you yeah i love that suffering
without a strategy
i think that's great karen just loved
that i think that's such a
really well put there um ryan what comes
up for you because obviously you're in
the
healthcare world right so i'm sure
you're mad busy your franchisees
your employees have got great
opportunities to do really well at the
moment but
then it's like yeah where where can we
stop are we too busy what are we doing i
don't know what comes up for you on that
i'm being blinded by
resilience and just yeah it's a really
good thing
what nicole just said but i think it is
that it's what you're going and then
talking about the time is your identity
as well what is it you as a person
what's your goal what you stand for to
make sure why you're doing the business
it's not just to make loads of money or
is it why am i doing this and
what am i creating in my business that's
what i've jumped out to me just
listening to both those two
and yeah it's happiness and
yeah i'm trying to put it into words
exactly but i think that's it exactly
that is what is my goal and why am i
doing it
and and not just not just monitoring
that message
yeah suffering without strategy you know
as long as you know that
the goal
i think it's worth going through that
resilience piece and learning that how
deep you got you have to
dig deeper how you know how deep you
have to dig basically
so as as you come to the end here what i
want to do
there's um two more polls that i want to
share with everyone that's still with us
um but tom i want to come to you and i
want to hear sort of everyone else's
thoughts and we'll sort of leave it
there unless anyone else has any
questions but
i guess the the question is tom like
what would be your
i guess free top tips we
really like sort of three top tips
recruitment mentors like what would be
your three best tips
on someone that's here with us today who
listens to this back that
does want to get better at bouncing back
cultivate more resilience or learning to
be more resilient
what would your advice or tips be for me
as a recruiter that
is really keen to perform consistently
bounce back consistently
don't overthink things it's probably my
biggest tip um
you know it can get you in a very
dangerous place overthinking things
um and look for evidence in
the everything you've done previously um
people can
yeah i've got people who work with me uh
people who left the business come to
other companies
that have not really believed that
they've got that
ability to to carry on um and they
there's evidence in everyone's life it's
just whether you're willing to
to look for it so i think really they're
the only term
as long as you've got um willingness to
um
to keep trying putting hard work as well
um
resilience is just not going to come
through doing very little um
but yeah it's life is tough and
you just have to keep going and um but
not too much that you put yourself in a
dangerous place
okay nicole we've had a question i'm
gonna ask you
keep doing this no i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry so
because i i just think you're in a
really unique spot here so like the
question is
ricardo's purpose so understand how
looking at someone's personal
achievements can give you a good
understanding about what you can expect
but it's also true that in some cases
people with no prior achievements can
turn things around in excel
what can you do to predict this that's
that's the question in that like how can
you predict that
yeah i mean you can't predict anything
really you can
you can have a plan and then you need to
keep adapting that plan to make sure you
achieve your desired result but i think
it probably comes back a little bit back
what tom said is it's all the things
that you've done
so far in your life not just necessarily
academic achievements but the things
outside of that
like what kind of person are you are you
someone that
really challenges yourself put yourself
out there tries new things
give things a go or not um so your
predictions aren't
aren't really there are they um but the
reality is it's about
what else have you done and what else do
you want to do as well sorry
i would say it's attitude as well i i've
got a reference
a guy who used to work for me um he was
with us
uh about four or five years ago he was
captain nine lives just kept going and
going and going couldn't get a deal
for the life of it and i was like he's
gonna be a recruiter he's gonna be a
recruiter he's gonna be a recruiter
for a variety of reasons not forms he
left
anyway three months later he then went
to a a uh a very big london
finance-based recruiter as a graduate
with nine months experience with us he
has smashed it absolutely smashed it
um and he's he's doing extremely well
still keeping contact with him
but you know he would be you know his
attitude every day would come yeah
he could get told to [ __ ] off 20 times a
day before he would come back in the
next day
pick up that phone and keep going and
going again so for me that would be
you know that's prediction of success
attitude yeah nice
so ryan back to the what would be your
best tips advice on how
if i'm someone who wants to cultivate
more resilience learn to be more
resilient what comes up for you what
what
free top tips would you give me i'll
just put self-care
extreme down time and keep working on my
attitude
they're the things that i would do you
could have good resilience
it's going to be that's emotional so
this time you're not in work
you need to be looking after yourself
and practicing good self-care that's why
i would suggest
anyone though but yeah that's that's
what i would think
so self-care attitude
well you're gonna get a good attitude
from having self-care and making sure
you're having
good down time so even if you're not
doing times yeah yeah just
getting out doing something that's got
absolutely nothing to do with work so
that when you come back to your fresh
face that's what i want yeah nice
and in the course i won't give you any
uh more questions i promise
what about for you what comes out for
you for two three top tips on how we can
learn cultivate to be more resilient i
think um
having a why is definitely one um
definitely for me knowing why you want
to do something and why that's so
important to you
and being solution focused is another
one
because i think that helps you sort of
stay logical
um rather than let emotion take over
which i think was probably my biggest
lesson in recruitment is emotion
took over far too many times um and now
it actually is quite a logical process
when you think about it
um and the last one i think self-care is
important it's like managing your
mindset
um really managing that and not losing
focus on what's important to you
as a person um and not getting
overwhelmed by the industry because
there is never a moment where you
couldn't be doing something in
recruitment you're always
there's always something to do um and
it's hard to switch off it's hard to
take you away
i'm the worst for it but ultimately is
it's managing your mindset
um that's absolutely key i love that
so having a why managing your mindset
and really
get good at being solution focused yeah
that's awesome
well i just um thanks everyone that
continues to tell us the whole time
just wanted to say a huge thanks ryan
the car and tom for
yeah sharing being vulnerable sharing
sort of their own experiences but
um thank you so much for your time and
uh really enjoyed discussing such an
interesting topic
so um a big thanks for for all of you to
join and a big thanks to everyone that
joined us so
um thanks a lot thanks guys
cheers thank you very much